[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and this week
we're gonna be talking about hold okie
Soho dokie are the escaping methods we
use in Aikido it is probably the kind of
technical stuff we should focus on the
most in Aikido because it's if we could
solve all our okie problems then we
could reposition we could reduce dance
we get everything going the way we want
it and so if we have problems that
Hinoki that's what we're gonna have to
do a ton of special techniques and extra
stuff that might not work out especially
if the other guy is a lot bigger and
stronger than us which is what we're
always accounting for an Aikido so
Hadopi is what we should actually be
spending a whole lot of our time
focusing on as far as the KU Meucci goes
so understand the Commuter are all of
our struggle methods they're not natural
to Aikido but they're the methods we
have to have an Aikido when we get stuck
in a bad position
sohe doki is one of the sections of that
and this week we're gonna be covering
all about the Hadopi so Hadopi is how to
break grips literally Japanese means to
disentangle to untie so I'm trying to
disentangle someone for me they've got
me and they're hooked up to me and how
do I get them off of me now if I got
them off of me then I wouldn't have to
be worrying about any kind of grappling
moves or anything else because I'm free
and once I'm free I can get about my
business
so remember 90 no we're not trying to
dominate the other guy we're simply just
trying to get to a position where they
can't dominate us so if we've mastered
hadou key that means even if they get a
hold of us we can get free really really
quickly so this week we're gonna talk a
lot about hadou key we're going to start
off today with the dough Dori and cut
the Dori so that's a single shoulder
grab I'm gonna get Josh over here and
we're gonna go to work for you guys
alright so let's talk about Hadopi now
from the Dori so cop the dories in
our dough Dori series it's gonna be the
beginning of where they catch me I'm
trying to move around here and he just
shot arm out and he managed to grab me
in how am I gonna deal with that
so Johnson's grabbed me here and a
the dories so this is a the door
now I have a ton of options understand
that I'm never gonna make hadou key
without trying at I know kinko as well
so I'm always going to be making tiny
Lenco position variation when I make
Hadouken so I've just cleared
and here he just grabbed me again and
again beginning again again so what I
want to do is make a position where it's
at least a little more difficult for him
to grab that's what I'm always working
towards so there is no hadou key and
Aikido without an attempted tiny link Oh
at the same time okay so when he's here
now what are my basic Hadopi I'm either
gonna go to a 45 from this I'm going to
go to a triangle from this I'm going to
go to a 90 from this I'm going to go so
Komal worry from this or I'm gonna go
ichiba varriya from this now I'm
probably not gonna eat any because
unless I make the clear he's gonna stay
stuck to me so while I can do a
technical Hinoki this way and I would
accept that on a test from one of my
students it's something we can't
necessarily count on because if the grip
doesn't break I'm not gonna make the
enemy so those are the basic ideas I'm
gonna be dealing with now core to icater
technique is son Cacoo sabaki the
triangle movement so this movement is
super good let me have you go to this
side so everybody can see really so I'm
here like this when I make a triangle
step I do a lot of good things I start
pulling his hand way over here which is
gonna make a little Kazushi in him which
is good so he stays on to me she's
getting a little Kazushi they're always
gonna be tempted to let go so notice
Josh didn't like the Kazushi so he just
let go here which is smart remember
that's what I want I don't care about
throwing this guy or doing something
super awesome to him all I care about is
hitting him to let go so if I lead and
he let go be hey that would be the best
thing ever
now while I'm doing this I'm also gonna
put one hand towards his face now look I
could be hitting him from wrong worth
and if my life were on the line I would
hit him prom word but I'm not expecting
to knock him out all I really expected
to do is freeze him in one position lock
into one position while I stretch myself
out as wide as I possibly can now you
see how much room I got I'm able to
really pull away from him here with the
triangle and also the triangle is now
controlling this area of contention so
if you look at our techniques are given
birth to the the the children of
positions you understand from this
position now if he continued to try and
dismantle this position we get all kinds
of techniques from this so triangle is
one of my tried-and-true I'm gonna work
triangle a lot in the objective the
triangle is just that to clear and
control the area of contention
another key technique I'm going to use
for
this is a soap bubble warrior so it
turned to the outside now if I just make
my turn to the outside like that I'm
probably not going to clear this grab I
might need to do that depending if
someone else coming in and someone's
coming on on this line I might need to
kind of try and move Josh there so that
way he'll defend me against that guy
but I'm also usually going to try some
kind of escape when I'm doing that now
one of the easiest escapes for this is a
Yahoo yoga or Yahoo gokyo so I bring my
hand up here like this and I turn out to
the outside this way to breaking it free
so as he's grabbing it here my hands
come up and I'm turning to move this
wrist out and pop out to the side like
this so that's our soap the more it with
a gyaku vocal opposite of gokyo so gokyo
goes this way Jakub oke Oke tries to
make the hand go this way and I'ma
lengthening those ligament so it's
harder and harder and harder for him to
hold hold on to me okay now those of
course can be con r.n together you can
make an adaption right so let's say I
try a soap bubble War II and it doesn't
work and he comes around that will
immediately lead me into this triangle
which is really nice now I can also try
Bucci mawari from this so I could go to
the inside here this position like this
now that will again really nicely con
rim right so meaning let's say I tried a
soap the Mauri didn't work then I heard
a triangle didn't work now I can try
Moochie muara here right now what this
has done for me he might let go because
he thinks his hands in a crappy position
that could happen
it also has set him up for nicely Chios
and other other setups for the Hadouken
and it's made this grip just generally
really weak so if I pull from here it
might more easily be able to clear my
shoulder so I put his hand in a worse
position while taking care of his desire
to improve his position over mine right
so these three really nicely con ran
into each other lots of other ones we
have in you and if you look online for
other material you'll find more but the
basic three you're going to be using
most of the time is either a soap bubble
re a triangle or an uchi malari
now other things that might be done
quickly that aren't quite as surefire
are things off the 45 right one of those
caught the Manucci now we usually see
Kaka Manucci is a setup for other
techniques but understand that the
Manucci is a Hadopi in and of itself so
he's grabbing here to go to the 45 and I
just hit this guy in the face boom he
might pop off of me because I hit him in
the face right so that is a Hideki in
and of itself and then of course as we
saw in the techniques video that if that
doesn't work out for me then the
techniques will be born of the new
position so I'm not trying to do that
technique - I'm not trying to do the
complementary to set up technique I'm
doing a technique because my contem
annucci didn't make ho dokey so these
are the basic three you're gonna use
there's lots of other little variations
and people to look up in our catalog of
techniques you can do that but those are
the basic ideas you're going to do from
the door next tomorrow we're going
to be talking about real cop that are in
a sheer ryokan Tori and how they relate
to this topic and and how some are a
little bit different than you'll see in
cop the gory I'm Christopher Hein thanks
for watching